No,
no.
I don't think we can talk about the
Caribbean without mentioning the
Dominican Republic.
It's a major tourist destination with
the largest economy and even the highest
mountain in all of the island countries
in the Caribbean.
Okay.
The Dominican Republic is a very,
very special place in Latin America.
I'm not only saying this because we can
find amazing places such as Punta Cana
by ib or Puerto Plata here among many,
many others.
I'm also saying it because this was the
very first place where Christopher
Columbus has men settled when America
was discovered in 1492 yup.
It's true for good or ill.
Everything started here.
This is where Latin America as we know
it began.
Okay.
It's capital.
It's Santa Domingo was the first modern
city on the entire American continent
here.
The first cathedral,
the first university in the first
hospital were belts,
but yes,
it's true.
If we associate the Dominican Republic
with anything,
it's going to be tourism.
The Sun Revolution.
This is by far the country's best face
and not for nothing folks,
the Dominican Republic,
it's trendy thanks to its 1000 miles of
coastline.
More than 250 miles of amazing Caribbean
beaches.
It's golf courses and huge all inclusive
resorts.
The country is experiencing an
impressive tourist banner.
Of course,
this is a story it has been developing
for a while.
See,
during the 1940s the then
plenipotentiary dictator of the island's
general,
Rafael Trujillo gave the order to
encourage tourism.
This was probably done with the
intention of filling his pockets.
That sounds the Malecon decentered Mingo
in the first luxury hotel in the city.
The hotel Harroway opens in 1944 years
later in 1968 the first legislation that
considered tourism development to be of
national interest was approved.
So as you can see,
an emphasis on tourism,
not exactly new.
Yeah,
but in recent years,
it has completely taken off.
In 2017 the Dominican Republic or
country with just over 10 million
inhabitants managed to attract more than
7 million tourists so quickly that the
country is expected to overcome the 10
million international tourists barrier
in no more than three years.
Course.
As you can imagine,
all of this,
he's got consequences in the last five
years.
Foreign direct investment in the tourism
sector has grown by more than 500% it's
multiplied by six times.
Nowadays the Dominican Republic is more
than 80,000 hotel rooms and this number,
it just doesn't stop growing.
Okay.
Give you an idea
to accommodate all these visitors.
In 2017 Dominican hotels opened 8,366
new rooms and an additional 15,000 are
under construction.
Then needle Medina,
president of the Dominican Republic.
The results tourism is already the
island's main economic activity as if we
take both the wealth this generates
directly and deans I rags and into
accounts.
It means not one out of every four pesos
generated by the economy from tourism.
We could say that the Dominican
Republicans can discovered and is
beginning to exploit its peculiar type
of foil and the truth is that in this
area,
it's almost all good news.
Jack Out,
one of their latest achievements which
happens in exchange for breaking with
Taiwan
People's Republic of China is opening up
to Dominican tourism.
The Chinese authorities have declared
the Dominican Republic a tourist
destination for all its citizens.
Of course we asked a moment because
that's not it folks,
the Dominican Republic,
it's got a different face because here
in this country we can find a lot of
lights.
We can also find a lot of shadows that
we commonly see today in Latin America.
So let's take a look at that.
The other face,
the Dominican Republic has achieved one
of the highest growth rates in Latin
America and the Caribbean in the last 25
years.
This strong performances,
actually men's achieving a higher
purchasing power parity as well as one
of the 10 highest per capita incomes in
all of Latin America.
I'd almost a $17,000 the Dominican
Republic is paired with Costa Rica and
to well above countries such as Peru,
Colombia,
or Ecuador.
Hold on a second because that's not the
whole story yet.
In spite of everything,
32% of all dominicans,
that is one in every three people live
below the poverty line.
The average life expectancy belly exceed
70 and infant mortality is almost five
times higher than in developed
countries.
Okay?
That may explain why we can find a one
and a half million Dominican's in the
United States and why often tourism
we're missing says are the second
largest source of wealth.
But having said that,
I think the question we can all ask
ourselves as well,
how can such a paradise not take off?
Well,
folks,
the answer is that this Caribbean lambs
has many of the evils that unfortunately
are all over Latin America.
Okay?
Yup,
Yup.
The and modern history,
it began here in 1492 now 526 years
later,
we can find a good reflection of the
best and worst in Latin America in this
exact same place,
but delving into this mass of the first
great points of darkness we can find is
these stubborn persistence in keeping
policies that have repeatedly been shown
not to work.
An issue that seems to reign in this
region of the world.
For example,
in matters of informal work irregular,
which is a serious problem that has
spread throughout the region.
See the workers who are exposed to the
situation to in formality?
Well,
it comes up more precarious conditions
with greater instability as well as
having problems obtaining financing,
whether that's to buy a house,
invest in the business or properly
educate their children.
And of course they have lower wages.
I mean this is pretty obvious because
the company will invest less money in an
employee who's hired irregularly,
but this is also a problem for the
governments.
For example,
when it comes to collect taxes,
smooth
one in the Dominican Republic in formal
employment affects six out of every 10
workers in this country.
Then I'm going to,
it's not decreasing.
It's growing in 2017 for example,
formal jobs were only created in the
public sector and well,
what does this info tell us?
While this is that formal hiring
involves many barriers and many burdens.
These can be bureaucracy,
taxes,
outdated regulations.
These basically mean that people have to
set up and pay taxes before they even
make a single dollar and all that.
Logically it makes it difficult for
private economies do create policy jobs.
So with this data in hands,
I think it would it make sense to say,
well,
hey,
we need a boost in formal hiring.
Well,
what's not working?
But unfortunately it doesn't work like
that.
The same goes for commercial policy.
You see in a country with a small local
markets as is precisely the Dominican
republics case,
the foreign sector is absolutely
essential.
This seems pretty obvious,
right?
It's,
well in this country we can basically
find two different situations.
On the one hand,
there's the free zones where the
companies in stalls have favorable
conditions,
both regulatory and fiscal,
which they provide in exchange for
basically only working in export swath
meeting a certain criteria and is being
approved by the government.
On the other hand,
they're raw of the more normal
companies,
which they're the vast majority,
well,
more than half of all exports come from
the free zones.
And additionally,
in recent years,
exports from these places have grown on
average 5% every year.
Yeah.
Sports from common Dominican companies.
Well,
well check this out.
Sorry.
So
upon seeing this,
the question I ask myself is if the free
zones work well,
why not extend their benefits to the
rest of the country so the Dominican
companies can become more competitive?
Well,
unfortunately that's not going to happen
either.
But then there's the issues of the
deficit,
public spending and debts,
which in spite of the great number of
bad experiences continues to be a vice
of many Latin American countries here.
The Dominican Republic is also not an
exception since 1990 public spending in
the Dominican Republic has multiplied by
18 yeah.
Public deficits.
It's almost a tradition.
No,
just hold on for maybe,
because you might be wondering now.
Well,
it's all,
I'm an only talking about a country
that's coming out of poverty.
I mean,
there's lots to do.
There's infrastructure that needs to be
created,
this ports,
airports,
roads.
They all need to be built so that this
country can grow.
But do you know what type of expenditure
grows this the most and no,
it's not public investments.
It's actually current expenditure,
which is multiplied by almost 30 since
1990 and of course the expenses have to
be paid partly with more taxes,
which slows down the creation of formal
jobs and investments and well,
partly with debt checkout was happening
with the Dominican debts,
with the devs and interest because of
course debts,
the hands interest.
Indeed almost one quarter of
governmental spending goes towards
paying interest.
That's the third largest figure in all
of Latin America.
And it won't stop growing.
Well,
despite the tourism sector is take off
this constant stubbornness with policies
that don't work,
explains why Dominican's have so many
problems and why there is still so much
poverty in this country.
I mean,
check out how this country ranks in the
global competitiveness index.
And what about politicians?
Are they involved in other things?
And this is not because the shadows,
they don't end here.
There's a lot more suspicion.
The Dominican Republic is a fantastic
country and it probably has a promising
future.
And wanting managers to take that big
step,
it really well be like a paradise.
Think about it,
good weather,
good beaches ans money.
It could possibly resist.
However,
today the Dominican Republic has two
other very important problems that may
be stopping the country from taking off
and it's one of those is corruption.
The Dominican Republic is among the 50
most corrupt countries according to
Transparency International.
Yeah.
That ride,
the Dominican Republic is considered one
of the most corrupt countries in the
world according to Transparency
International's ranking,
Oni,
Venezuela,
Haiti,
Guatemala,
and Nicaragua in a worse situation in
Latin America here,
corruption at all levels is very common.
Suspects range from the current
socialist presidents,
any limit.
Dina who was accused of having finance
does electoral campaign with bribes to
the police themselves.
In fact,
it was in the Dominican Republic for the
construction company.
Oderbrecht in stalls is coordination,
sends up for the bribes that it paid
internationally in exchange for
contracts,
and of course,
many of these bribes remains them almost
a hundred million dollars as far as we
know.
These were received by politicians and
officials in exchange for concessions,
work awards and public contract.
Yeah,
but unfortunately
that's not all.
The other problem which is growing is
drug trafficking.
The Dominican Republic is considered one
of the most important bridge countries
and it's narcotics distribution centers
by the United States.
Drug traffickers have a problem
exporting drugs from Venezuela.
There are few commercial flights,
little container shipping,
no tourists and a collapsed fishing
sector,
but the Dominican Republic,
1400 kilometers away has it all.
In fact,
according to the dea ends,
the European intelligence services
nowadays,
the Dominican Republic is one of the
main transit countries for narcotics
that go to the United States and the
most frequent for cocaine shipments
coming to Europe,
and of course this is an important
issue,
but that's something we're going to talk
about another day.
In any case,
let's be absolutely clear there are
problems that unfortunately are common
in the entire region.
The Dominican Republic has achieved a
lot in recent decades.
It's certainly a fantastic place and it
has a promising future.
In this video,
we just wanted to show you some of the
reasons why this country is not doing as
well as it should,
so I really hope you enjoyed this video.
Please do hit that like button if you
did,
and don't forget to subscribe for brand
new videos.
Also,
don't forget to check it off.
Friends at the reconsider media podcast,
they provided the vocals in this episode
that were not mine.
Also,
this channel,
it's made possible because of Patriot on
man's our patrons on Patrion.
Please consider joining them and
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage.
And as always,
I'll see you in the next video.